welcome everyone to an exhibition of
gptj a 6 billion parameter
transformer model from a collaboration
between
benwang or king of lowell's on github
kamatsuzaki and elia there
a i there is so much that we can do with
just this one model that sometimes it
may be confusing just what a transformer
model is actually doing or what things
like view shot learning even means
so for the very first example we'll take
a very high level approach through
what's going on
and then we'll run through a variety of
examples that i think you'll find
extremely impressive and rather shocking
that it all runs from the same model for
this high-level approach i'll be
obscuring away
various bits of code just to make things
more clear to understand the order of
operations but i will put links in the
description for
everything you could possibly need
depending on how deep you want to go
towards
understanding how these models work
actually running the model as well as a
text-based version and
of the run through of all of these
examples we'll start with the context of
transformer models are quickly advancing
the field
of artificial intelligence now neural
networks do not work
in string data they work in array data
so the first step that we're going to
take here is to
convert this into an array and we do
that with what's called a
tokenizer so we can come down here we
can say tokens is equal to
tokenizer dot in code and again the
tokenizer has already been loaded here
and this will be the starting context
then we can go ahead and just print out
and display these tokens and we can see
here this is the array representation
of this string the next step in our
pipeline is going to be to pad
this input vector this is because the
input layer to our neural network is of
fixed size
in this case that's 2048 or 2048
sequence length of tokens can be input
into the network but in this case we
have
much less than that so what we do when
that is the case is we pad
the front of that vector so for example
we can output padded
tokens and we can see it starts with a
bunch of zeros and then ends with
uh our actual vector the next step is
essentially to pass everything through
the model there are some parameters here
the first one you'd probably want to
take a look at is the generative length
which is specifying how many tokens that
you want the model to actually
generate otherwise we also have
temperature top p
and top k these are all parameters that
you can tune to adjust the variability
and outputs but for now we'll keep them
as the defaults and we will get
our actual output we get various
information from the output variable but
the actual output tokens that we're
after
can be found here these are indeed all
of our tokens but they're in a slightly
strange
shape this is just simply due to how
they're generated for now we'll go ahead
and store these
into these this output samples variable
and we can check the shape which is a 1
by 128 by 1. what we really want to do
is be able to reference these tokens in
sequential form
and since this is a numpy array we can
use some numpy magic
and boom we have our actual sequence of
tokens
since this is an array of arrays because
it's a batch
even if it's of one we can iterate and
then de-tokenize
the sequence and what we get is that
continued generative output
we can then shorten this a little bit
add some color and we can see
our full output here in yellow we've got
the original
input and in cyan that's the generated
output so feel free to pause the video
and give that a read it's
pretty exceptional i seriously doubt
anybody would be able to tag this as
being written by an ai
unless they already knew so not only
does this model appear to have
a grasp on the english language and
grammar and all that it also appears to
have a decent grasp
on just the subject of deep learning
giving a pretty darn good summarization
of what it is
now we can certainly quibble about how
much of this might be memorization but i
invite you to
for now hold those quibbles because
we're really just getting started on
the subject matter that this model knows
and the things that it can produce
for example one of the types of data
that this model was trained on was
github in stack exchange which of course
includes programming we can try to get
the model to write a regular expression
for us by adding a comment
in the code that suggests that the thing
that's going to come next is indeed a
regular expression that will find the
dollars
as we can see when the model finally
finishes it did indeed output the rest
of the code for us and it produces what
i think is mimicking stack exchange
where someone is likely
asking a question and then there's maybe
an answer and some more information
we can then just copy the code part
paste it into an editor run it
and we can see that it indeed did parse
out the dollars
the string formatting included an extra
dollar sign so we could either fix that
by either removing
the dollars you know the backslash
dollar sign from the
regular expression or from the string
that we printed at either way
it worked pretty well one other thing to
note is that since there are
some degrees of variability we can
actually run this exact same input
prompt again
and get a different response again in
this case let's just grab the regular
expression
copy it over to the editor print it out
and again the different output from the
model but the same thing happened
it worked it gave us a valid regular
expression
okay so regular expressions with python
code works pretty well
very cool but there's still a whole lot
more here let's try another programming
task
opencv using a very similar method we'll
import cv2 specify a file name and then
nothing else we'll just slap in a
comment that says hey we'd like to open
the image and find the edges
again we get some output it continues
actually writing more code than we
initially cared about at least for now
maybe you're interested in that
the other code and doing those things
next but for now we're just going to
take the edge detection only
copy and paste that into the editor in
this case the code saved the output as
an image rather than doing something
like cv2.m show but that's fine
we can pull those up and we can see
here's the edge photo and the original
full color photo
it indeed did find the edges using kanye
edge detection
and again all we did was just import cv2
specify a file name
and said here's what we want to do how
do i do that
okay how about something with a few more
lines of context and a few more lines
required to complete
the objective in this case we'll start
with some common tensorflow and keras
imports and then we'll load in some data
set that we have and then again we'll
use a comment to suggest the following
code should be a three layer convenient
with a 64 by 64 imagery
with five classes i tried to pick sizes
in classes that are a little more rare
so something like 28 by 28 and 10
classes is going to be
super common for example 64 by 64 might
be common i don't know
five classes is pretty rare i tried
looking for image data sets with five
classes i couldn't really find many so
hopefully that's good what we get in
return is the entire code
for a convolutional neural network
including training
and testing again we'll copy the code
and run it and sure enough it's
fully functional in training it looks
like it's ready for testing data too
what happens though if we change our
mind and we actually want to have a
two layer convolutional neural network
and seven
classes again i think seven classes is
fairly rare
for the model to get this right it would
really need to understand where one
might actually
make a change i.e the final dense layer
to account for some specific
class count in this case we get a
completely different output
including even the styling of how the
network code is written and how the
network is actually built but again we
get completely
valid code it is indeed a two layer
confident this one even specifies the 64
by 64
shape the previous code was also correct
it was arguably better it was actually a
bit more of a dynamic
handling for the input image shape than
just
hard coding the shape but this is what
we asked for too
again we can just copy and paste this
into an editor run it
and indeed it also works this model is
actually training and is a totally valid
code to the spec that we asked for
while this is really cool it's not just
python code that it can do
for example we can open up with a html
and body tag
and then make a comment about an
upcoming button that will return a
function when clicked
gpdj goes ahead and adds some paragraph
text that says if you click the button
your browser will be taken over
okie doke no skynet vibes or anything
like that
and it indeed adds some code for a
button
which does come with an on click handler
gbdj
also ends up closing off the body and
html tags so this is actually a complete
html
file so we can copy paste and view it
for ourselves
pretty uneventful since the takeover
function doesn't actually exist but so
far gptj has done
everything we've asked of it so how
about we add another comment that says
here's a takeover function it will send
an alert that states the browser
now belongs to us on the first run
there's a bunch of stuff here it looks
like it's valid code in
some way but i'm not sure it's doing
what we actually want it to
and i really want and expect something
simpler so
we'll just run it again and this
looks much much better so copy and paste
that again refresh the page and let's
check it out
beautiful does exactly what we wanted
while these are extremely impressive
examples and we could keep going with
programming this model's
not a programming model it's really more
like a general purpose
language model that just so happens to
be able to also
write code alongside all of the other
things it does
gpdj was trained on a data set called
the pile and here you can see a tree map
of the contents of that data set sorted
by color showing if the data
is academic style from the internet
pros dialogue or something else entirely
then within those categories we can see
the actual source of the data
so actually stack exchange and github
the
source that contains programming
information they aren't even the
majority
of what this model has learned from this
model
also has knowledge of things like
medicine law mathematics
general conversations and much more
scrolling down a bit we can see a table
of how the data set in this model was
weighted
and for how many epochs it was trained
a massive area of research is available
just in coming up with
balancing a data set like they've done
here and getting the results
like they've done here so what else can
we do
we can ask generic questions like who
invented calculus
and just see what the response continues
with from there
but we can also structure these prompts
in such a way so as to encourage the
model to
follow our structure so for example we
can use q colon
and a colon in this case where we ask
about voltage for a standard us home
outlet
i also limited the model's response to
just be up to the
next new line but we can see that indeed
the answer
is correct we can also let the model
continue for longer
our original question of when the u.s
revolution began
is answered and that date is probably in
reference to the revolutionary
wars beginning but then we can see that
gptj
went ahead and also just made up more
q's and a's
as they progress they get a little
stranger i think and less based in any
sort of reality generally the first
answer that you get back
is indeed a correct answer but then it
kind of gets weird so
i suspect maggie's diners are in many
places and
i don't think hawaii has a hockey team
either alaska doesn't but
i don't think hawaii has a professional
one either and utah's
state name actually originates from an
apache indian word
but still the structure of question and
answer
it continues to be mimicked by the model
like it's
it's trying to stick with that structure
for us
so continuing along we can see that the
q and a structure happens again when
our first answer is correct ish i i hope
no one is actually changing their oil
every 3000 miles but big oil change
would like you to believe that
i suppose if you wanted to drain every
last drop of oil it would take
up about an hour to get every last drop
and the final answer about not filling
your gas after an
oil change is a bit weird i don't think
i've ever heard that i don't think that
has any basis so that's kind of curious
to see i think gptj
made that up the concept of the
structured prompt can be
quite interesting for example we can
check out what happens when we mimic a
sort of
chat log between a human and a bot and
in effect we're creating a chat bot
from an otherwise just generative
language model
we're starting off with whatever the
human said let's say we leave a space
for the bot's response and we're just
going to collect up to
the new line we get a reply and the bot
just says
hello back but we can continue this chat
log by asking what the bot is up to
prompting another response this can go
on for
as long as we like and the discussion is
completely contextualized as the entire
previous discussion is passed through
the model every single time
so the bot should stay relatively on
topic
we can also remove the next line only
bit and let the bot just generate more
of the script for us
so no longer much of a chatbot but also
interestingly
the bot decides to indeed close off the
chat quite quickly since we did say we
were done anyways
and taking a shorter section of the
script before the goodbyes without any
line limit spawns
a different behavior translations
we can check these and see that some are
decent but it's definitely not the best
i think we've
we've seen before that the further we
let gptj
walk on its own the sillier it can get
and i think this is especially true as
soon as the kind of structure goes away
or gets changed
by the model we can adjust those
parameters that we referenced earlier to
try to get a handle on this if we want
but it is going to be very specific to
exactly what you are trying to do we can
also be
more specific ourselves and we can
actually ask the model to go ahead and
perform a translation for us and usually
in these cases where we try to do
directly a translation it does do a much
better job
here we've done a spanish translation
very successfully we can also try
something like
german and we can see that that indeed
also worked again
being kind of a next line prediction or
translation
these tend to work quite well but we can
also let gptj
do a few translations and just let it
kind of pick what does it want to
translate to next
and again kind of as expected it's
randomly choosing its own translations
and it does okay but it also gets pretty
quickly sidetracked
gptj despite getting sidetracked can
generate
long form responses quite well when the
structure
doesn't change or isn't suggested that
it might change
so when you're asking new unique
questions or making
new unique translations it's very
difficult for the model to figure out
what should come next in q a for example
it could be
literally any question and answer for
translation it could be
any language to translate to if you just
want an
article this is totally doable and is
also similar to the much larger code
blocks that we saw earlier with like the
neural network in tensorflow
chaos i won't hang on this whole thing
long enough for you to read it but if
you want you can pause the video and
give it a read it's fairly well written
the arguments
aren't really the best that i've ever
seen so it's kind of comical and
whimsical to
argue for ai regulating humans because
it can hang out in your closet and give
you flowers on your birthday and control
your thermostat
but regardless of whether or not the
argument could sway you
it can make the argument in long form
text
other interesting examples are lists
where here for example we list
three similar-ish books at least likely
to be enjoyed by the same person
and we get a list of other similar books
though there are some repetitions here
it's about in line with what you would
expect with this starting book list
we can even take this a step further and
just start naming some stuff so without
even saying
you know x list so gpdj
understands that these are television
shows and it picks a couple more that
are similar to the ones that we've
already listed
not only does gptj understand multiple
spoken languages
and programming languages it also
understands
the emoji language
this isn't a general intelligence but
the model
is generally intelligent it knows a lot
about a lot of stuff and i encourage you
to play with this model if you're able
to
and think about how you might use this
model's abilities
in the end it's just a generative model
but you've seen that with
a tiny bit of logic added it could be a
chatbot
or a question answerer it can write code
for you it can recommend books and
movies and it can honestly do
probably a ton of stuff that we don't
even know about yet because so few
people have had the opportunity
to play with these gigantic large
language models
so with that in mind a huge thank you to
everyone involved in making
gptj a thing i have spent way
too much time just simply playing with
this model and being
absolutely blown away by what it can do
it's truly incredible it
has been very hard for me to make and
close a video like this because i don't
think i'll ever feel like i've
even remotely done this model justice
and showing you all of the things that
it can do
and still have that video be less than
10 hours
so hopefully this was enough to pique
your interest and
show you some of the many capabilities
of gptj if you can't run it locally
there is also
a web based prompt that you can also
check out to just play with gptj
obviously you won't be able to directly
add logic and stuff like that but you
can still tinker
in closing i will share a paper someone
from the gbtj
channel and the la there ai discord
shared with me and that's using a
7 billion parameter language model so
this one gptj is 6 billion but 7 billion
is not
too far off and what they've done is
taken a large language model
and then also trained an image
captioning model kept the language model
frozen and the inputs are encoded image
data
from the image captioning model along
with text that are structured
like they would like and essentially
they're mixing few shot natural language
with
this encoded image data and the results
here
are essentially few shot learned
captioning styles
which is crazy i think the fact that
something like this
is even remotely possible should dispel
anyone's thoughts that all these models
do is memorize and compress
it's no doubt that there's a lot of
memorization and compression that's
going on
but there is something else going on
if you'd like to learn more about the
goings-ons of neural networks at the
most
base components there's a book you may
have heard of once or twice on my
channel
called neural networks from scratch you
can learn more at
nnfs.io
that's all for now thanks for watching
and until next time
you